hello everyone and welcome to a very
exciting game from round 8 of this
year's European uh individual
Championship it's Alexis Arana versus
Anton korob Anton corbovin's Soul lead
going into this round uh and uh both of
them without a single loss uh up until
this point so it's gonna be very
exciting a very cool line of the BOGO
Indian defense I don't think we've had
it on the channel as of yet uh so let's
see this uh at this incredible fight uh
we have pawned a D4 by Alexa and Knight
to F6 by Anton C for E6 Knight to F3 and
Bishop to B4 this is the BOGO Indian
defense with Bishop to D2 and now Pawn
to C5 uh there are other replies of
course but this is a very well known
line Bishop captures and now see
captures on B for black already has a
double B Pawn and now G3 is the main
move here but here we have E3 by Alexa
B6 Bishop to D3 and now Bishop to B7
with Knight B to D2 and now we have a
castles King Side by both players so
castles muscles point the A5 and now
there there is a game that reaches this
exact same position where A3 was played
uh between
um uh all gageria and the daddy avoid he
was actually played in the ninth edition
of the blondes versus uh brunettes uh
tournament that was organized in Russia
and um uh yeah I I've actually seen this
event that they actually have a
tournament where they have brunettes
playing against the blondes and not not
only that it seems to be a very
successful event as this was in the
ninth edition of that but okay here we
have instead of a three we have Rook D1
and it is now as of move 10 that we have
a completely new game we have Fanta D6
uh Ponte E4 and now Knights the C6 just
nicely continuing development Knight to
F1 the Knight is being re-maneuvered to
E3 Ponte E5 inviting D5 but just a nice
Bishop to C2 so the D4 Pawn is nicely
protected so Rook to C2 Rook to C1 and
now Pawn to G6 with Bishop to A4 seems
to be in an odd move because the bishop
looks really nice on this diagonal and
it doesn't appear to be doing all that
much here but it actually comes with a
very strong idea now black has a problem
if black captures for example Knight
captures on D4 then after you capture
with the Knight Pawn captors white will
play F3 uh solidify the position and
next move capture on D4 and if if you go
for E captures on D4 which definitely is
possible then the idea was to just
eliminate the Knight and after Bishop
captures You're Gonna Play Queen
captures on D4 and have a beautifully
positioned Queen here this is a
backwards D6 Pawn you're gonna attack it
and okay
it can be played by both sides but
nothing wrong with this for white
however here we have Queen to E7 and now
it's uh it becomes much more interesting
Knight to E3 here Alexis sacrifices a
pawn uh for uh an attack that seems to
be much stronger than Anton would would
anticipate Knight captures on D4 Knight
captures and D4 e captures Queen
captures and now Knight captures an E4
so grabbing that pawn opening up this
diagonal seems to be a bit too much to
give black but what was uh Alex's idea
Knight to G4 this was the idea now if
you play a weird move let's say you play
something like Rook to d8 or something
you just receive Knight to H6 Checkmate
so this is the the thread just mating
one so here Queen to G5 stopping that
and attacking the Knight and now Bishop
to D7 also one of the uh moves that are
possible uh by by re-maneuvering the
bishop to this diagonal and again it
seems like a bit of an a bit of an
Overkill maybe uh Rook 38 and how do you
uh if Rook C to d8 how do you uh survive
this is white it seems that your Bishop
is attacked you can't really move the
bishop anywhere if you move it all the
way back then the Knight hangs the idea
was this Pawn to H4 and after Queen
captures Now Pawn to G3 and there
doesn't seem to be a move here for black
you have to play something like like
Knight to the D2 even it seems like
white is lost here but there's just no
move for you to make you can play Knight
to D2 to try and trade Queens for
example Knight to F3 check would win
over the the White Queen but now just
Knight to F6 with check and um there's
uh nothing that you can try Queen
characters on H4 is coming next so the
problem is uh if Queen to G5 then comes
Pawn to F4 and you lost your queen
because now if Queen to H4 you can just
play Rook captures on e4 okay you didn't
lose your queen you you blundered your
piece here but you're completely lost
there's no defense against Knight to F6
uh which will Fork the king and the
Queen and if you move the queen uh then
uh again Knight stage six will just be
another Checkmate so there's really
nothing you can
uh you can even try here so that's why
after Bishop the D7 Rook the C5 was
played and now we have Rook C to D1 uh
Pawn to H5 chasing away the Knight and
now Rook captures an E4 uh H captures
and G for first uh you of course cannot
um go after the Rook then Knight to F6
check becomes possible so H captures and
G for Rook capture Sanji for and now
Queen to E5 offering a queen trade and
here we get this very very exciting end
game Queen captures Queen captures Rook
captures and now Rook 38 and here Rook
Gita D4 even though uh it's uh possible
to play Rook captures on G6 it's very
hard to calculate all the way if it's
winning the problem is let's say you go
for real characters F characters and now
of course Bishop to E6 check you have to
win back material King to f8 now Rook
captures with check and now King the E7
if you go King the if you go King to G7
then just Rook to D7 so you have to go
here but now again you force a trade
Rook the D7 checking characters who Rook
captures and now let's erode captures
and see four row captures on B6 with
checking F7 defends the pawn G3 stopping
Checkmate and now Rook the C1 checking
to G2 and there's Rook to A1 where black
will win back
um uh some material for example a3b
character spawn captures Rook captures
and you will get you will get this end
game three pawns against two pawns the
white has three to one and on the king
said black has one to zero on the queen
side whether this is winning by force uh
I have no idea probably it's possible to
win this with perfect play uh but uh
Anton uh Alexey decided that he wanted
to try a different uh approach Rook Gita
D4 and this is what he comes up with so
Keen to f8 and now Bishop to B5 he
offers a rook trade and then he will
start collecting sorrow captures and D6
Rook captures now comes Bishop to E4 you
have to move the bishop if you just
bring the king into the game then Rook
D7 check wins the bishop so Bishop to E
4 and also you want to undermine those
Queen side pawns Rook captures and V6
with Bishop to D3 now going after the C4
Pawn Rook the B8 check King to E7 and
now upon the B3 defending the pawn and
now of course Bishop to B1 going after
this A2 pawn bishop to A4 and now we
have Rook to E5 going after Checkmate so
Ponte F4 attacks The Rook Rook D1 check
King to F2 Rook to C1 and now Rook to E8
with check
uh King goes to D6 we have Rook the E1
now uh sorry Rook D1 offering a rook
trade and now Rook the seat to check
black of course does not want to trade
material as he is down material Rook the
E2 with check with Rook to C3 and now
adjust the Rook to D2 with check with
King to C5 and Bishop to E8 going after
the F7 Pawn luckily your Bishop is also
defending here so just Pawn to F6 uh and
now Rook to D5 with check King to B6 and
now Rook the D6 with the check came to
C5 and now Rook the D5 with check uh we
have King to B6 and now uh just going
back with Rook to D2 uh you you don't
want to allow any uh well if you allow
Bishop captures on A2 then you just
allow black a bit too much then A4 will
just force create a pass Pawn so here we
have King back to C5 and now Pawn the
age for sarana decides that it's time to
create a second weakness and then he
will be able to exploit his advantage
and here we have Bishop to E4 by Anton
and we reach this position where uh
White is better of course but there is
one move that is particularly beautiful
I think this is my favorite move of the
game so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the absolute strongest move
for white uh while I give you a couple
of seconds
foreign
always being a true Master of the end
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is Pawn to F5 so
congratulations if you've spotted that
this Force creates a past H Pawn or or
you know a past g-pawn or whatever you
want
um and there's really nothing that Anton
can do to survive this the problem is if
you capture with the bishop then just H5
and again you get a past G pawn and the
The Rook will not be able to come to the
G file to help defend against promotion
and of course uh if you go for uh for
captures then Rook the D5 check you've
uh hung the bishop on on F5 so instead
after F5 G captures and F5 was played
right away but now Pawn to H5 uh we have
Pawn to A4 trying some counter play on
The Queen side but just Bishop captures
an A4 we have Pawn to F for now trying
to get the Rook over to G3 to capture on
G2 maybe but just Rook to E2 goes after
the bishop Bishop captures and G2 nice
nice little maneuver there but of course
you're not gonna capture with the King
if you capture then F3 check and black
is back in the game but here we have
Bishop back to D7 now comes Bishop to F3
attacking The Rook uh but of course uh
Alexey will not react to this he just
advances the the pawn as the pawn is
also hanging so if you move the Rook
then you lose the uh the pawn so here
Ponte upon the H6 and now Bishop
captures I need to we have Pawn to H7
the pawn is now Unstoppable Rook to C2
are threatening uh uh Discovery here but
it doesn't matter just h8 queen and the
position is now of course completely
winning Bishop to G4 check King D1 you
will uh have the uh give up the bishop
and the Seven Rook to C1 check now as
the pawn and Bishop are controlling
these four squares of course you cannot
go to the king side because the black
Rook will just continue checking you so
you have to go to D2 Rook to D1 check
King to C2 and Rook captures on D7 and
it seems okay black has a bishop and the
rook in the past Pawn maybe he can
counter the White Queen the problem is
Queen characters and F6 and the the king
is white in the open there's just no
defending um everything just let's say
this is this is a threat Now You're
Gonna Lose Your Bishop so Bishop to D1
check was played but now King to C1 and
it was in this position and move 57 that
Anton korbo resigned the game and the
what a spectacular victory for Alex uh
sarana who deals Anton korob of his
first loss um uh after being undefeated
for for seven rounds and takes the lead
in the European individual Championship
2023. so here what uh what can you play
Here There is really a hard possession
you could play Pawn to F3 but there's
never any hope of actually advancing
that pawn The Rook can't really move it
has to defend the bishop the bishop has
to stay here defending the pawn the pawn
cannot Advance as that square is covered
and um it's just a very very easy to win
this at some point you will win the B4
Pawn or you're just gonna play A3 put B4
so there are many ways to win this and
of course Anton knows this yeah so yeah
here on move 57 he resigned and a
wonderful wonderful victory for Alexei
sarana as round nine already started uh
some wonderful games are being played
there if you have any of your favorites
do use hashtag suggestion and I will
look into it so yeah that's the game
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Global ravishing reptiles YouTube
Joe Wilder's Ryan Cavanaugh and Rob uh
boshof for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here and thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event and whatever else
happens in the Chess World thank you all
I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day